I've been getting told for years that I
look like the girl from sex education
who is from a Mackie and she plays one
of the Barbies in the movie pretty much
because Greta and I thought it would be
funny
hey guys we were gonna do like this
whole joke about us looking similar and
how did you know this I did not know
this anyways and then once we like got
all dressed up as our Barbies we were
kind of like we don't actually look that
similar yeah like when she's got her
brown hair and I've got my blonde hair
we don't look that similar so we didn't
put that joke in the movies but when
people come up and say I loved you in
sex education I just say thank you thank
you so much